everybody listening to this wants to
make better content they want to reach
people more through video specifically
YouTube but across
platforms what are some of the
observations you're seeing in modern
communication that are maybe principles
we could apply to our day-to-day content
creation well one I think we're having a
revolution of
communication I uh what Instagram and
Tik Tok and the development of social
media has done is it has heightened the
value of the ability to communicate
quickly
and uh in in a really succinct and
Powerful way Twitter did that with
writing when you can only have 140
characters for me it was like a dream
come true I I love condensing and
finding a way to put something really
profound in a capsule that explodes so
when everyone's complaining about the
words I'm like no this is beautiful it's
a tiny canvas have you ever seen the
modal Lisa it's so small I I took my
daughter to live because she wanted to
see so badly when I walked up and I saw
how small it was like what did Da Vinci
you run out of canvas what's the deal
and I thought Mariah would be so
disappointed cuz she was maybe 10 years
old and she stood there and it was quiet
she never said a word and minutes went
by and finally she said I could stand
her stand here and look at her all day
long and I realized that if you have
true genius you just don't really need
that large of a canas I think that's the
way it should be with language with
words and with communication if you
really have something to say then
harness the ability to say it in such a
way that the fewer the words the more
powerful and that's the thing I would
say to most people on social media Mo
most people trying to develop their
message if it takes you too long to say
it you don't understand it yet
storytelling is crucial to business
success that's a quote from Entrepreneur
magazine um but I hear about
storytelling you're an all-time
Storyteller you're as a communicator at
Mosaic Church you are often telling
stories Weekly right and tying it into
your content yet I feel like it's also
kind of a buzzword there's all kinds of
people like oh storytelling storytelling
but you're like okay so what does that
mean
practically how do I actually Implement
that so why do you think storytelling
matters and how do you actually find in
craft stories that we could weave into
our content what are some practical tips
storytelling is almost as important as
living a
story and I think the problem is that
we're moving people write to
storytelling rather than story
living the reason I can tell a lot of
stories is because I live a lot of life
and I and I I remember oh probably 15
years ago I mean can you imagine being
my wife having to listen to me speak for
so many decades right it's just brutal
and she came up to me one day and she
said you told the same
story and when she said that she was
saying a
lot and I think I got on a plane and I
went somewhere and begin to experience
life again because what I heard her say
was you need to live something new
something fresh something
real and the reason I can tell 10,000
Stories is I've lived 10,000 lives and
and I I I think a part of the problem is
that if you're having to borrow stories
from people you're also borrowing lives
rather than living one and so in every
book I write there might be one or two
minor exceptions but I never write a
story unless I've actually encountered
that person
or had an experience related to it and
that way every story in my books are not
the result of research they're result of
living and so I I I'm absolutely
convinced that storytelling does shape
the future I think 30 years ago I wrote
in my first book that whoever tells the
best story shapes the culture and and
one of the things that would always
frustrate me is that the truth trapped
in a bad story will never win over a lie
told in a great story and we see that
even today when we're dealing with the
conflicts in Israel and Palestine
everyone's working to get the stories
out and people don't even look at the
facts they just get captured by a story
and that story for them becomes reality
and that's why stories are so important
the entire of human history is
transported by stories and nothing else
it's the stories that we told each other
through the Roman Empire and the
Egyptian Empire it's stories we've told
ourselves through Western history and
Eastern history those stories shape us
and they carry us and they Define us and
so really what we need to do is first
live a great story then tell that story
well and in that story the values and
principles that you want to pass on will
transfer from you to someone else for
The Listener
who maybe is digging to see what story
have I lived but as they dig they
discover well I did overcome stage four
cancer well I did
my wife and I were on the verge of
divorce but we made it work and now
we've built a strong marriage and we
want to help others do it but I was
overweight and now I'm fit and I'm
energetic when I think about the
creators listening to this they figured
out how to succeed in real estate and
now they teach others how to do it a lot
of Educators but maybe the block for
them is but how do I package it and tell
it because some people when they tell a
story they're like well if I'm going to
communicate this thing I'm going to need
3 hours where you're like well should it
be 3 hours and your 12 minute YouTube
video how do I consolidate it is there
any basic framework when you think about
distilling a story and then putting into
it a piece of your communication yeah
it's a brutal one and um and I know I've
even got negative push back on this okay
and but I'm gonna say the way I've said
it no one cares about your story okay
they care about their story and if they
can see themselves in your story then
they will care about your story but if
all they can see is you in your story
they won't care about your story so the
key to crafting a great story is making
it profoundly human where everyone can
see themselves in it if you enjoyed this
podcast and are ready for some deep dive
YouTube strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my
one-hour on demand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com